hello reject nation I'm Greg alpha cat
Anuradha
Oh bb2 it McKenna Verado Twitter
Instagram Paul's are there lord knows I
do
yes he does praise Jesus and Ken I'll
brought a comedy on Facebook FB for
short yeah hey cat yeah you make adult
jokes sometimes you're sending 14 right
I sure do
what else well again I'll rod up if
there's ten hit in adult jokes in
children's movies
felt like about another guy I want to be
like murder
Oh God talk to me time terrible go to
remove my Dremel 800 Louie
my the guy was I think if I were to
guess I know there's one in Aladdin
where I think he says something Aladdin
says something I'm correct different to
providing information right now let's
find out if these are actual hidden
jokes or miss animation stuff screen
rants a great channel our had a great
website
recent years filmmakers to God is better
at making kids movies appeal to add
usually by filling it with jokes and
references that the average kid won't
even understand there are a lot to
choose from but these are just a few of
our favorite adult jokes that younger
audiences never caught your are screen
rants 10 hidden adult jokes in
children's movies face gen the wacky
universe of Space Jam anything can
happen after a cosmic amusement park
experiences and different attendance the
owner starts to scout out some you tell
when the Looney Tunes become the target
of a cosmic amusement park owner looking
to boost profits they wind up with their
freedom depending on a basketball game
thankfully the movie Tunes have Michael
Jordan on their side but the opposition
is tough the Monstar is cheap by
stealing the talents of real-world NBA
stars and the players are giving
physicals to try to understand why they
suddenly can't play basketball the
doctor drops an erectile dysfunction
joke that definitely stayed under the
radar of most kids are there any other
areas besides basketball so you find
yourself unable to perform Shrek in
Shrek movie Thank You Man peaceful
existence is ruined when an evil Lord
banishes all fairy tale characters to
live in his beloved swamp shrek heads
off to see the lord and convince him to
reverse the decision but even before he
meets Lord Farquaad tickle of mr.
particularly crude joke try saying lord
farquaad's name twice as fast and you'll
see the r-rated nickname some fans claim
is an obvious joke
not to mention Shrek and Donkey implying
that his massive castle is making up for
a shortage somewhere else do you think
maybe he's compensating for something
mondaya short maybe we dispute so far
Monster House shows how bad things are
so literally merges or at par on the
thumbs trio of kids we wanted their
basketball on the property the kids
decide to investigate inside the house
is modeled after the human body with
references to anatomy worked right into
its architecture the parts of the house
never had below the belt but when a part
of the human anatomy comes close the
filmmakers couldn't pass up the gag the
even adults might miss and that was the
uvula
so it's a good cartoons transit wealth
alive action but it means you're telling
us I'm not on stage in the original
story when gorilla deville talks to
stars Roger and Anita it's revealed that
the couple is also expecting a baby to
go along with the upcoming litter of
puppies gorilla snaps our gaze to Roger
it makes a crude joke that is at best
keeping and cheating and at worst you
see Alan please you have things they may
go like either one Steve's at home in a
Disney movie The Little Mermaid our
mermaid start this Disney classic falls
in love with a human she makes a deal
that goes horribly wrong
Ariel winds up with a prince in the end
but the wedding scene didn't kill the
rumor that Disney likes to hide adult
references in all their films conspiracy
theorists like to point out that the
minister is far too excited to be
leading the ceremony while Disney's
defenders claim his Noddy needs are
obviously the explanation either way
Disney took note and only copies
produced during the original run
contained the scene in its true state it
was modified for the 2006 review
muhahaha caper Muppet Treasure Island on
each side regional what Denny Muppets on
a search for treasure while navigating
pirate-infested waters the Muppets have
always been as popular with adults as
kids and are known for incorporating
dirty sometimes dark humor into their
show one of the film's more risque
seeing sees Kermit and Miss Piggy
reunite with the pink pirates discussing
her past lovers
she then greets ten curries Long John
Silver a little too intimate me we've
encouraged to assume they've also not
oh no Tim - Madagascar wears a crazy
face curtain another kid is a must
sometimes those clever solutions make it
into film the animal adventure
Madagascar a group of Kakarot animals
escape their New York zoo to wise up on
the island of Madagascar out to the
lioness prone to hunger adduced to
loosen ations which means his friend
Marty the zebra starts to look a little
too delicious when the ride home arrives
are you ready to fetch a starving alex
says Marty tries to flee the attack
shelter a seemingly meaningless string
of words oh don't take a second to think
it over it will realize the words first
letter spell an entirely different work
you're watching Nickelodeon in the 90s
are you being funny Chuckie bill will
and the rest of the Rugrats day the
cartoons bullying movie saw Tommy his
friend set out to return his newborn
brothers dil to the hospital and I was
gonna maybe slide by almost completely
undetected a conversation between two
newborns turns dark as one laments the
loss of her umbilical cord the second
babies there's longingly a purse or cell
block
telling her to be happy that's all they
took mrs. Doubtfire okay which I'm
currently at Ricky's Reaper fires kit
Debbie badger nothing new for home wins
Robin Williams in the role you know it's
going to be plenty of academic custody
battle with the soon-to-be ex-wife but
disguising himself as the elder mrs.
Doubtfire actually worth a chill really
returning you starts courting as one
people who actually saw the movie as
children might now realize that the
villainous still was actually decent guy
but most of the sexual innuendo is
probably went completely over their head
no conversation proves it's better than
mrs. Doubtfire attempt to scare him off
by discussing
I'm hobby all of the trick completely
meaningless to the kids just laughing at
a man dressed as an old one who
presented his competition how are two
individuals using the go-to L / cows
reworks adventure problem let's cosmic
criminals set out to find a mystical
City and gold it wouldn't be much of a
movie if things went smoothly for the
heroes Tulio and Miguel the journey
isn't all bad though especially for to
really enjoys the company of a beautiful
woman in shell in fact you might be
enjoying it a little too much in one
scene the camera pans across a couch
before Chell appears from below followed
by a satisfied Tulio
considering the sound tray before they
were interrupted and the fact that their
heads pop up from two different places
the animators seem to be implying
something far more adult than a PG kids
movie but we'll let you decide Aurel
whoa my mom Bartlett do we miss any of
your favorite heroes movie let us know
in the comments and be sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel for more videos
like this one especially our dirty
Disney video click and enjoy she's
learning what intercourse oh yeah
wait a minute yeah yeah I'm just
thinking Paul like where her head was I
came up in his head
I guess maybe gosh kg not know how these
things work by a satisfied - but we'll
let you decide
whoa see she's on top I can't get it up
thank you oh because of where she's at
yeah oh no I see that too that's that's
my eye shadow oral yeah yeah that's it
I'm familiar with what that is I think
maybe I should be more familiar yeah oh
yeah wouldn't be single right now
there's more to it than yeah i mean i
i've been i've had oral from any one
girl once three or less every years
good movie awesome if you had it for
more than one girl on calling us blonde
you know what doubles game with double
standards there are what's the for
record one okay if you say it fast its
pop Lord Farquaad Farquaad are wedlock
watch my club
look what like I know but it sounds like
an insult like but watch nugget that's
an insult [ __ ] what what you heard that
before
[ __ ] wat i win that be an insult I mean
is that an actual work stop being such a
[ __ ] what does it mean it's bug lighting
stuff the fact that it's a real work
there's gotta be like a definition for
it nearly synonymous of fuckload but
perhaps more use for measuring than
counting that's going to cost us a lot
of money folder slang pejorative
derogatory floral or insult to denote
someone of substandard intelligence yeah
[ __ ] what granula Greg Alma chuckles
Greg [ __ ] what album yeah all right
when you nickname great know just set
myself up for a lot of comments can't
wait to check out the comments on this
video hundred one Dalmatians I don't
think she was implying that she was
having sex with zombies you have been
all these puppies are yours are they
you've been sleeping with it so many
puppies little soldier person or in real
that is definitely an erection in the
Little Mermaid
yeah cuz if it was me there would be two
yeah that's totally like yeah who's
gonna pointy add me what do you have
right there so did we got an e oh my
gosh you really thought that they would
have taken dapper to re-release the
earthís tradition like it did the
animation studios if they like comes
like they huddled together and lay up
like happy I was like all right
who's gonna do a good digging ah dude
rostros like a holy animators are hers
New York Italian
you woke up a little bit of a right now
and you know what I mean we got some
moisture to the buter yeah yeah yeah the
Long John wanted another seven so no
Long John him to into yeah oh man this
also implying that that Kermit and Miss
Piggy have sex do you have sex
also that Miss Piggy is did she found a
few adventures I mean the fact that she
is a pig having sex with a frog that's
just a little [ __ ] species come on you
know you should never mix and generally
shouldn't even put two races together
local came out with me okay me too so
yeah yeah maybe we would maybe
interracial love yeah we call that a
callback saying if this boy is a great
example you can sign up recant
Alvarado's comedy classes yeah crowd on
Yelp s fantastic review fantastic and
classes are only twenty dollars an hour
for a half-hour class so she makes
really close it's like you don't have
good with the numbers here that's why
I'm half asian but I suck with the
numbers alright let's stop being racist
Gregg I'm only a racist against you
alright then
Oh what's this looks the sugar high iced
tea is that is that a thing that people
say no all me oh you put it together
Chrissy they're so quick oh I would have
suffer ever they're like sure their
honey eyes teen what the hell does that
mean I Chapter II in code like that
forget your you grew up religious yeah
hey you want to give me a king icicle
sausage succotash we're trying to say
give me a kiss
King okay pickle improvised acronym
skill that comes out over the lesson
plans that was Rosie
give me another word
country umbrella nose tart oh my favor
word what I did use to describe most of
the woman I've dated
country umbrellas young brother young
fellas I know it starts oh good that's
good or not in the second week of can el
Dorados comedy course classes you will
learn the art of improv yeah excel that
as well good you'll learn oh well where
when why oh you know never deny don't
ask question s question about the
relationships man shut up improv Olympic
hey oh he was talking about circumcision
decay in the Rugrats oh yeah hey mister
packed off hopefully the dark jerk for a
road resume honey kind of isn't that
what circumcision in below and like a
piece your penis was passed on yeah I
have half a penis who the circumcision
that's all you said six inches early
yeah cuz only have it's half a penis now
the original Eliza squirrel but it is an
important surgery at an abnormality
Toby like a brittle and everything
that's what they replied and redress you
need a penis reduction surgery
oh the thing that's the thing that
happens on that thing you know I have a
friend it's just too much and nobody
likes no he wants to date him so he's
all alone I'm that guy and mrs. Dale
Parker I never services Doubtfire family
no I always felt that was like in the
middle of some sort of family no not
like a chili g13 I thought wait a pg-13
family movie it's been a guy pretending
to be a woman the whole time yeah you
know that's like r-rated material varies
with the interracial comedy love the
same man like this
oh it's nowhere near that tuxedo yeah
dude that movies just mean it's but I
haven't seen to see recently well I've
heard things wildly inappropriate
wow man PG my eyes MC 17 wait you're
saying have a vagina wherever where he
goes into the business what's wrong with
having a vagina Greg you can't put it in
anything I can put it in things you put
if there is a cake batter there's a
frosting I could mess it buckles into
the cake frosting make an imprint I can
put it I could fit in something really
want you yeah we're out of comedy
classes render a yoke you talked about
help survival described as green red red
yes again but I never asked you that
question before
okay that's the clearest sign right now
oh the cab ride alot up Twitter
Instagram enter I like King Alvarado
comedy humping look you check subscribe
to this channel the real rejects yeah
and so I got our patreon for awesome
rewards
go there oh let's call our night